We need to save for our future,
the country's becoming prosperous,
need to share their prosperity with
their citizens and let them spend that.
China,
for example,
consumes less than 40 percent of its GNP
is hardly a is hardly appropriate.
We need to find the fora that will
connect not a limited set of aging
societies dominated by the Atlantic
Ocean,
but a much wider set of rapidly emerging
societies to provide the function of
being a kind of global steering
committee.
As we address a central,
a global concerns,
we need to find ways in the United
States to support a more inclusive
democracy in a more inclusive
prosperity.
If our people are going to be willing to
accept the kind of international role
that the United States needs to take.
If the world is going to remain stable.
Some of that goes to healthcare.
Some of that goes to a that the tax
system and a much much else.
We need to forge some kind of
international approach to dealing with
what are really the existential threats
around nuclear weapons.
The nuclear proliferation around global
warming,
the two events that have the chance to
profoundly change the terms of life on
earth 50 or 100 years,
uh,
from a now.